[Music]
david's in dallas hi david how are you
hey dave and tom it's great to talk to
you and pick your brains on something
today sure what's up
uh well i'm 56 um i've got 228 000 in
six different debts including two
student loans my wife's undergrad
uh and then my
parent plus loan for my kid who has been
on your show doing a debt-free screen
back in 2018
um and then also master's work that i
did
and y'all are educated up around there i
hope you're making money what's your
household income
about 150. that's good okay actually
about 160 now come think of it
um so what i'm trying to figure out is
given
you know my age given the debt level um
is it wise for me just to stick with
baby step two
or to
go ahead and start putting some into
roth um to start making some headway
there what do you and your wife do for a
living tournament uh we both work in
education
she's a teacher and i work in i.t
what are you doing i.t
i'm a
director i manage email voicemail
telephone systems all the
my group handles everything that all the
end users touch
so you're making how much of the 160
uh about 102
okay
are you allowed in your current contract
to take any side consulting gigs
yes good you need some so here's hey
here's what
number one the answering question is no
you don't need to go get a roth ira
the instead what you need is a vision
for paying off this debt very very
quickly so that you're not panicked
about the fact that you have no
retirement so what if i said let's go
completely out of our minds bizarre for
two years and be debt free
you guys both are high intellect you're
both very intellectual people
and if you're not careful you're going
to think yourself out of a visceral
response to this problem which is the
fastest way out i want you to get so
pissed off that your eyes are bleeding
and your brain quits thinking and all
you do is go make money like a maniac
and get your income up at two and a
quarter and live on beans and rice and
you don't need to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
and if you even get on amazon again i'm
gonna throw your computer in the dadgum
trash and oh by the way you're not going
on vacation you need to get your button
gear and get this mess cleaned up that
kind of emotion instead of using
intellect to fix this problem because
you use intellect to fix everything
because you're so freaking smart
well if i were that smart i wouldn't be
in this
[Laughter]
hey man
you are both you are both highly
educated very analytical people am i
right
pretty much yeah and so you're trying to
figure out a way around this is why you
called
and instead i'm throwing dynamite in the
middle of this thing
blowing you up man
well i mean i do pick up
stuff that's primarily in the fall
um it goes basically from august through
january ish and and i'm trying to add to
it for the spring i mean i end up
picking up additional stuff through work
working games where i pick up you know
four to six thousand dollars a year
additional
i just think i'm talking about enough
i'm talking about 50 000 yeah that's
five bucks i mean that's 50 bucks a pop
you you got to make more than that i'm
talking about 50 grand you're in an
industry where you can contract out and
manage it from your home while your wife
is asleep and go bananas that you're and
i want you to do this for very long
but but i want you to have no life so
that late so that very quickly you have
a life again because here's the thing
let's pretend that you lost your mind
and people thought you were crazy like
i'm describing and you guys just went
bananas you scorched earth on the
lifestyle and in two years you were free
at 58. how rich are you going to be
making by then probably 180 000 a year
without working crazy
and having no payments in the world for
the first time in your recent memory
you're going to have so much margin that
you're going to be able to throw so much
money you're you'll probably be worth in
excess of a million dollars by the time
you get to 65 starting at 58.
but you have this barrier in front of
you and you have two years of hell to
bust that barrier
can y'all do that
yeah
the only challenge we have is our our
daughter single parent of an infant
and having to care for her sometimes and
my wife having to juggle working late
sometimes but we can figure that piece
out
it can also be it can also be a really
challenging conversation
sitting down with your daughter saying
we're going to be able to we've got this
plan
which is going to benefit you and this
young granddaughter in the long run
exponentially more than scatter shot
babysitting here in the current
well no it's not that she works 787p and
there is no daycare
that we found anyway we found
inexpensive daycare 45 bucks a day while
she is at work and while we're at work
but when we get home one of us is there
watching that doesn't mean that i can't
go ahead and work you know doing i.t
stuff etc so so
here's the thing um
yeah there's a lot going on and you have
some barriers
the truth is though the best way to get
where you want to be not the barriers
the best way you well there are
uh they're things you have to work
through whatever it is you can call them
we can call them whatever we want to
call them but the best way to be where
you want to be
uh
nine years from today is what i just
described think about it go get it done
the highest probability
of you getting there in the shortest
amount of time is what i described
from all of my 30 years of doing this i
don't know a better way and it and it is
not a better way to limp into retirement
with three different kinds of student or
four different kinds of student loans
hanging around your neck and you've got
a half butt roth ira
and that's where you'll be nine years
from now if you try to just short
circuit this system instead of punching
this thing in the nose
and but there's something that has to
happen inside of your
deep down where you growl that's not
your brain yes
it's the i've had it moment and you're
just howling at the moon and you're
going no more i've worked my butt off i
got this stupid parent plus loan i've
got this kid single with a single mom
one of my grandbabies and i love them
dearly but dead gum what a mess and oh
my gosh and i got to fight through this
and there's something you're just going
to double up your fist and just get
after it and that's the best way out of
this it's the fastest way out and i
don't know a better way
a modified version of that to tell you
if i did i would because it's gonna i'm
what i'm prescribing is a horrible two
years
i want you to have a miserable two years
so that the next 25 are excellent